let's look at some examples of
one-dimensional elastic collisions with
no external forces with between two
particles so suppose I have particle 1
and particle 2 and we have them moving
on a frictionless surface and let's
choose a reference frame in which we'll
call the laboratory frame in which the
initial velocity of particle 2 is 0 so
our frame is called the laboratory frame
and in this frame we're thinking of
Parga particle 2 as our target and the
target is at rest and particle 1 is
moving in with some initial velocity and
so here is our initial picture and then
our final state both the target and the
particles can be moving so we'll just
indicate the 1 final and we'll have at
our target is also moving with V 2 final
and we have I hat so let's now look at
some examples where we're analyzing this
type of collision in which both energy
and momentum are constant and for a
particular example that we want to look
at
we'll have m2 m2 is twice m1 now for our
two equations that we're going to write
about we'll choose components and we'll
write our energy equation as one-half m1
v1 X initial squared plus one-half m2 so
now we're going to write 2 m1 but the
object 2 is at rest so we don't have to
worry about that one yet and so our
initial kinetic energy is just equal to
the final kinetic energy one-half m1 v1
X final squared and now I'm going to
substitute in to m1 for the mass of m2
be 2x final squared and that's our
energy condition and then our momentum
condition is that the incoming momentum
one-half X and
is equal to the outgoing momentum m1v1
x-final
and again I'm going to substitute for m2
that's to m1 the 2x final and these two
equations represent a system a linear as
a system of two equations with two
unknowns
we'll treat these this is Givens along
with the initial velocity of particle
one and our target here is to solve for
the what 1x final and B 2x final so we
have two equations and two unknowns now
it's a quadratic equation so we have to
identify from problem solving strategy
we have to identify which quantity we're
going to solve first and so let's solve
for V 1 X final which means we need to
eliminate V 2 X final and the way I'll
eliminate V 2 X final is I'll use the
momentum equation and notice that the MS
will cancel in the momentum equation and
so if I divide through by 2m in the
momentum equation and bring this term
over to the other side equation 2 a
becomes V 2 X final equals I'm dividing
through by 2 one-half V 1 X initial
minus 1/2 B 1x final so this gives me a
target v 2x final I can substitute into
there this equation again can be cleaned
up let's clean it up before we can get
rid of the house we can get rid of the M
ones and so the quadratic equation that
we're going to be working with is V 1 X
initial squared equals V 1 X final
squared and I'm dividing through by 2 so
I have the factor 2 plus to be 2x final
squared now that's our energy equation
and here's our momentum equation so if
we substitute
this in and square it we can now
substitute and we get B 1 X initial
squared equals V 1 X final squared plus
2 now we make our substitution so that's
1/2 V 1 X initial minus 1/2 V 1 X final
quantity squared so let's now expand
this and we have to be careful not to
make any mistakes V 1 X initial squared
equals V 1 X final squared now if I pull
the 2 out I get a quarter in front and
divide that by a half so I get one-half
V 1 X initial squared plus another one
plus a 1/2 V 1 X final squared those
represent the squaring out those two
terms now the cross term will have a
factor of 1/2 in the front but a factor
of 2 so we have a simple cross term of V
1 X initial B 1 X final
now when we let's collect terms let's
bring everything over to this side so we
have a zero equals three-halves b 1x
final squared minus 1/2 B 1 X initial
squared and minus B 1 X initial B 1 X
final now I always like to just write
this up in a simple way to use the
quadratic formula so I'm going to divide
through by two-thirds and I get minus
one-third v1x
initial squared minus 2/3 V 1 X initial
v 1x final and this is now a simple
application of the quadratic formula
negative B is plus two-thirds v1 X
initial plus or minus and we're going to
interpret those two roots in a moment we
have the factor two-thirds v1 X initial
squared minus 4 ay C so that's another
minus sign with the plus so that's plus
4/3 B 1 X initial squared all to the
square root and everything divided by 2
now here let's just look at this factor
this is 4/9 plus 4/3 4/3 is 12 9 so
that's 16 ninths which is very
convenient because when you take the
square root that's 4/3 so we get equal
to 2/3 V 1 X initial plus or minus 4/3 V
1 X initial divided by 2 now we see that
there is two different roots so when you
add them you get 6 32 32 V 1 X initial
divided by 2 so there's one solution and
when you subtract them you're getting
2/3 minus 4/3 that's negative 2/3
divided by 2 so that is another solution
v 1x final
equals negative one-third b1x initial
now let's think about the meaning of
these two possible solutions this
solution has v 1x final equals V 1 X
initial so that's the initial conditions
just repeat it and that will always be
the case
one solution will describe the initial
state and the other solution will define
the final state you can check for
yourself that if you just put VX one
final into this equal to VX one and an
initial into this momentum equation then
V 2 X final is 0 which just repeats the
initial conditions so this solution is
the initial state and this solution here
is the final state now just to complete
the picture B 2x final well that's equal
to 1/2 V 1 X initial minus 1/2 times V 1
X final but V 1 X final is negative 1/3
so we have 1/2 minus 1/2 times minus 1/3
so that's 1/2 plus 1/6 which is 4 sixths
or 2/3 DX initial so that's 2/3 the 1 X
initial and that represents the solution
to this particular problem now of course
what the what you want to do is you want
to check we know the momentum condition
is already satisfied but just as a check
you would like to put it into the energy
condition just to make sure that when
you square these things out you get the
right terms however we're very confident
of our result because we've already
reproduced the initial conditions and
that wouldn't happen if we made some
algebraic mistake so that by itself is
the sufficient check that this is a
correct solution one thing we should sit
back and think about is that when we use
the energy and momentum that we're
inevitably dealing with quadratics and
so we expect to use a
to solve a quadratic equation at one
point and here was right here now we're
going to find another way to do this
by linearizing the system which will be
a lot easier